East Africa is in the thick of a
brutally unusual rainy season and it's
set to get worse to tropical storms are
expected to hit the region in the coming
days for weeks torrential downpours have
triggered landslides and flash flooding
that that toll stands at 250 with some
three million affected they are growing
fears of starvation and disease outbreak
the wet weather is due to warmer
temperatures in the Indian Ocean in a
moment we'll get the latest on the
response from Nairobi but first this
report from the submerged Kenyan village
of Cocola on Parker these floods may
have killed scores deprived thousands of
their homes
no they threatened to wash away the dead
not if these villagers have anything to
do with it beneath best Mound lies
Joseph a bongos late wife Maori no okay
you yeah Kabaddi we're putting big rocks
on top of the grave to prevent the
coffin from coming out due to these
floods toka the downpours have only
compounded the grief Joseph married his
wife just last week in Italy the person
buried here is my mother-in-law when we
woke up we found that the water was
almost removing the coffin from the
grave body with the grave fixed for now
attention shifted evacuations more rain
is on the way
and like many here David a [ __ ] who is
desperate to get his family and their
things to higher ground but no one here
can escape the devastation this extreme
weather has unleashed
[Music]
we don't have farms to cultivate and
even our cows were taken away by the
floodwaters
so we have a big problem the arduous
rebuilding process will have to wait for
now survival is paramount
for more on this our correspondent Edith
Kimani joins us from Nairobi Kenya hello
Edith so clearly people still need help
how much support are they getting from
the government at the moment it's truly
very difficult to gauge because this is
a situation that is unfolding as we're
speaking so government is sort of trying
to do preventative work as well as
search-and-rescue but there has been
quite a little bit of money that's been
pumped into this the government of Kenya
has put in the equivalent of about two
billion u.s. dollars and I do know that
the UN emergency fund has also
contributed three million dollars so
quite a lot of fundraising being done in
and around this issue as I said as its
unfolding so what is the main challenge
of people right now right now for the
ones who have survived obviously it is
just the initial trauma some of these
people have lost not just their homes
but family members livestock their
entire livelihoods because we're talking
about entire families being swept away
this is their main source of income and
beyond that it's where to sleep where to
get food these are all institutions
which have been swept away so we're City
seeing a situation where people are
conversing and rather converging
desperately at schools and hospitals but
they simply not enough to go around so
we're seeing quite a bit of respiratory
diseases and folding and there's still a
big question as to what will happen to
their number that's still being added
let's talk about long-term effects yeah
what long-term effects could all of this
have on the region well we do know that
there will need to be a serious pump on
infrastructural redevelopment roads and
hospitals which have been swept away as
I said but the immediate threat is
diseases malaria which is already on the
rise in some of these regions is now
threatening to take back or rather to
take up more lives and muck of a bigger
concern in the region is food security
this is a region the Horn of Africa
which has just come out of a drought and
now there are flood
the food that was supposed to be
harvested will no longer be there so
there's a huge huge concern on food
security not just in Kenya but in
neighboring Somalia and South Sudan as
well okay now more greens are expected
throughout the month of December how
prepared is the region to handle this
Edith not very in fact the government of
Kenya together with the governments of
the countries that I've spoken spoken
about asking for international
assistance in this this is not something
that was expected it's not unusual to
have rains at this time of the year we
call them the short rains but to have
them be so rather the water levels to be
so high is what is unexpected and we're
being told is because of the heating of
the Indian Ocean so there's a huge
conversation or a bigger conversation to
be had about climate change and how to
mitigate any of these future disasters
okay either Kimani the W correspondent
in Kenya thank you